Ja wir leben in einem zeitalter in dem unmögliches möglich wird der absolute nullpunkt gelder geht nicht dachte, man
unmöglichkeit - gerade in der physik ein deutsches forschungsteam hat aber ein atomares gas geschaffen das
Negative calvin werte annehmen kann wie soll das gehen und warum das ein hinweis auf die mysteriöse dunkle energie sein könnte
Das jetzt in klicks um science-fiction und danke für diesen spannenden themen vorschlag in den messenger herzlich willkommen
Ja und wie ihr über die messenger tender gramm facebook whatsapp und instagram mitmachen können dass er vater am ende
Des videos es ist eigentlich unumstößlich je langsamer die chaotische bewegung der teilchen ist desto niedriger ist die temperatur bei minus
273 grad celsius oder eben null kelvin verhalten sich alle teilchen still und die unordnung
Verschwindet nichts geht mehr der absolute nullpunkt vielleicht habt ihr im physikunterricht ja auch schon mal was von der sogenannten
Boltzmann verteilung gehört da geht es um die verteilung der bewegungsenergie
verteilen einfaches beispiel wenn man wasser energie zuführt erhitzte sich und die wassermoleküle
bewegen sich immer schneller sie erhöhen also ihre bewegungsenergie
Allerdings nur im durchschnitt gesehen denn tatsächlich ist es so dass die einzelnen moleküle
Eine sehr unterschiedliche energie aufweisen manche sind sehr langsam einige sind sehr schnell und es sind nur wenige
teilchen die sich sehr schnell bewegen denn diese energie zustand ist nicht so wahrscheinlich wie ein zustand mit niedriger energie ein
forschungsteam von max planck institut hat tatsächlich ein gas realisiert bei dem diese verteilung genau
anders rum s und sich mit dieser umkehrung auch das vorzeichen der temperatur
Um kerth es wird negativ wir haben nur wenige teilchen eine niedrige energie viele weisen dagegen eine
Hohe energie auf und so bedeutet das konkret die teilchen haben eine negative
temperatur angenommen doch jetzt kommt das paradoxe daran dass
Ich eben nicht kälter als null kelvin sondern heißer naja es ist echt
absoluter wahnsinn dazu einer der beteiligten forscher ulrich schneider die umgekehrte boltzmann verteilung ist genau das was eine negative
Absolute temperatur ausmacht und die haben wir erreicht dass gas ist sogar. Heißer als bei jeder beliebigen
positiven temperatur die temperatur skala hört bei unendlich einfach noch nicht auf sondern springt zu
Negativen werten leute da bin ich jetzt auch absolut wirklich baff unter null kelvin und trotzdem heiß und extrem
heißes gas hat eine temperatur unter null
Kelvin was okay langsam was bedeutet das jetzt genau oft lassen sich solche
energiezustände mit dem bild von rollenden kugeln einer landschaft
veranschaulichen das tal oder kleine mulden stehen für eine niedrige potenzielle energie hügel oder kleine erhebung für eine
Hohe potenzielle energie je höher die kinetische energie der teilchen ist desto schneller bewegen sich die kugeln wenn die temperatur
Positiv ist dann ist die gesamte energie der kugeln groß
sie verteilen sich in der landschaft auch auf die bereiche hoher energie wenn man sie unendlich hoch erhitzen könnte wären sie unabhängig von ihrer potenziellen
energie an jedem ort anzutreffen und zwar mit der gleichen wahrscheinlichkeit wenn dann weiter energie
Zugeführt würde und man die kugeln weiter
Aufheizen würde wären sie vor allem bei den energie zuständen mit, hoher energie anzutreffen sie werden dann noch
Heißer als bei unendlicher temperatur dann wäre die sogenannte boltzmann verteilung umgekehrt und die temperatur
kippt ins negative paradox klingt das schon dass eine negative absoluten temperatur
Heißer ist als eine
Positive doch das ergibt sich einfach aus der definition der absoluten temperatur von natürlichen systemen und wasser da ist das ganze nicht möglich schließlich müsse
das system dafür unendlich viel energie
Aufnehmen können was eben nicht möglich ist denn nötig für solch eine umkehrung der bordwand verteilung ist quasi eine obere grenze für die energie
Wie eben die spitze eines hügels das forschungsteam des
max-planck-instituts für quantenphysik münchen hat sich genau das zunutze gemacht in ihrem
Experiment kühlten sie rund 100000 atome in einer vakuumkammer ab und zwar auf eine temperatur von
wenigsten wenigen milliardstel kelvin dann setzen sie
Laserstrahlen ein um die atome thermisch von der umwelt zu isolieren die atome ordnen sie auf einem optischen gitter an dass die
laserstrahlen gebildet hatten zwar können sich die atome von gitta
zu gitterplatz bewegen doch ist ihre bewegungsenergie
Nach oben hin beschränkt das forschungsteam setzt sich jedoch nicht nur der bewegungsenergie eine grenze nach oben sondern ihre gesamten energie
potenzielle und wechselwirkung energie eingeschlossen dann brachten sie die atome an ihre obergrenze der gesamtenergie
Und damit war die temperatur
negativ weil jetzt eben sich viel viel mehr teilchen eben
Hat eine hohe energie- und damals mit diese boltzmann verteilung umgekehrt also - einige milliardstel kelvin
War das ganze jetzt
Kalt heiß naja ok das tolle an der ganzen sache der zustand der teilchen ist bei negativer temperatur genauso stabil wie bei positiver temperatur
dazu simon braun einer der beteiligten forscher haben die kugeln aber eine negative
Temperatur dann ist auch ihre bewegungsenergie schon so groß dass sie nicht weiter zunehmen kann daher können die kugeln nicht
hinunter rollen und bleiben auf dem hügel liegen die energie schranke macht das system
also stabil und damit sind wir wirklich in eine vollkommen neue dimension vorgestoßen
Jetzt sind wärme kraftmaschinen denkbar die eine effizienz von mehr als 100 haben denn sie
Können nicht nur energie aus einem heißen medium ziehen so wie wir es bisher kennen sondern eben auch
Aus einem kalten anders als bei
positiven temperaturen würde die effizienz nicht gemindert werden nämlich dadurch dass ich das kältere medium aufheizt und so ein teil der energie
Des heißen mediums wegnimmt aber auch für die kosmologie ist das ein spannender ansatz denn
thermodynamischen diese negative temperatur der sogenannten dunklen energie zu er weiß man noch nicht wirklich viel
forschungsgruppen gehen aber davon aus dass diese kraft dafür verantwortlich ist dass sich der kosmos immer weiter
ausdehnt und das obwohl er sich wegen der anziehenden gravitation der materie
Im universum eigentlich zusammen ziehen sollte die ähnlichkeit zu dem münchner experiment die atome des gases haben sich nicht wie gewöhnlich
abgestoßen sondern angezogen sie üben also einen negativen druck aus und wegen der negativen temperatur
Kollabiert die atomwolke eben nicht obwohl man es erwarten könnte wirklich absolut irre
Ich bin gespannt ob es dazu bald weitere erkenntnisse gibt denn dieses gas wurde bereits
2013 entwickelt danke dafür dass, er das thema gefunden hat und mir auch prozent vorgeschlagen
habe das werden wir eben absolut
durchgegangen ansonsten wenn ihr da mitmachen wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp oder per telegramm
Oder eher können wir auch bei instagram und im facebook messenger
folgen dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
täglich und garantiert und zu begrüßen gibt es ein kleines goodie einfach hier drauf trinken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
Genau mit der glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken riesen atom zum ersten. Mal. Im. Weltall hergestellt ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran